it was crazy is this whole animal
kingdom thing but one thing that scares
me that you were doing when I walked it
is playing these fucking shooter games
dude that game is a real problem Jamie
and I have been going to war for the
last what two months in this star like
two months ago yeah maybe like that I'm
in full-blown addiction mode what is the
threat like I what's the thrill yes do
you see us we're all sweaty and
adrenaline oh well great ass time I
walked it looks like I just finished
working out it was like crazy Jamie and
I were going to war we go to war we
talking about shed - we go to war I
tried it's fun it's fun we kills me talk
shit to me it's rough you like god
dammit he got me fuckers is that a game
where people can go online and play with
you - no we don't people we jump online
this is the game this is the game yeah
dude it is a fun ass fucking game it's
called quake champions okay and people
right now listen and going god dammit
he's talking about yeah but me and Jamie
have been and and Jeff our other
employee been playing this fuck see okay
see this isn't bad because they're like
characters like I was playing one where
it's like human beings again when you
shoot somebody like I got scared when
you get scared to go into the next room
because you're really that nervous like
it freaks me out
these shooter games are too realistic I
grew up with Frogger dude this is like
you're always in like some sort of a
castle yeah and the people that you're
shooting against they don't look
anything like a person they look like a
cartoon character but the graphics are
sensational but more importantly like
the gameplay is very precise and you you
have to have like real hand-eye
coordination and skills like you learn
things like tactics you learn how to
move around maps you learn how to
control resources controlling resources
is giant like that thing that guy just
picked up yeah that's like 175 health
and you want to get all the armor that
you possibly can then you also want to
be like clever about weapons choices
because you're always engaging at
different distances different kinds of
fights you like sometimes you're stuck
in like a corridor and sometimes you
know you're in an area where you
they can't shoot you but you can shoot
them if you use the right weapon man you
need to bring back to old-school Atari
that one red button that ran off that
one red button did everything on the
joystick you never killed a guy with a
railgun once you kill a guy with a
railgun you'll understand wait I don't
want to kill a guy with a really a
person I mean I know everything why you
do it if he jumps at me and I shoot him
in there with a railgun laughs Ikey shot
me in the face of the day with a rocket
and I was like dude in the mug I was
like in the mug it like right in my face
and I exploded like my whole screen just
becomes a big red splatter I'm like fuck
it's fun I can't handle it man it's too
much for me